(pleasant music)
- So I'm going to be
talking about the complexity
of the single cells
that make up the brain.
We've heard a lot about normal populations
and how they're organized,
which is quite amazing
but if you zoom in and look
at any one of those cells
whether they're astrocytes
or neurons or microglia
within the brain, inside those cells
is a plethora of subcellular organelles
that are playing a huge role
in how the brain is operating.
I just want to draw your attention
to some of these organelles who,
if they don't function properly
can lead to many of the
neurodegenerative diseases
that we're aware of, so for instance
mitochondria that you can see here.
Defects in mitochondria
lead to Parkinson's.
Many of the Parkinson's disorders.
Lysosomes, proteins that
comprise some of these lysosomes
are responsible for
frontal temporal disorders,
and the endoplasmic
reticulum which you will hear
a lot about today, is very much at play in
where mutations in proteins
that shape that organelle
underlies a variety of
spastic paraplegia disorders.
So in order for us to really get,
I think, at this neurodegenerative
aspect of the brain
and how it ages and deteriorates,
we need to understand how these organelles
that comprise the cellular components
which is the unit of the
whole system of the brain
are organized.
So this is a classic
transmission electron micrograph,
a 90 nanometer slice through a cell
to really reinforce the
complexity of these organelles.
What we want to know is more information
about the three dimensional organization
of these organelles, and how proteins
are dynamically distributed.
That's one thing we want to know
and I'm going to be
talking about other layers
of information that we're
now beginning to get
in terms of the
organization of this system
thanks to high end microscopy technology.
So let's start with the
3D organelle shapes.
This is, as I mentioned, is a transition
electron micrograph
slice of 90 nanometers.
What that means is within
that 90 nanometers slab,
you have no Z information.
Everything's flattened,
but thanks to technologies
like the focused ion beam
scanning milling system
that in combination with
scanning electron microscopy,
we can now slice through the cell
at very thin sections,
four nanometer in this case
and we've used that in collaboration
with Harold's beautiful
FIB-SEM system at Janelia
to begin slicing through parts of the cell
to reconstruct particular organelles
in order to understand how these
organelles are shaped in 3D
and how they communicate
with other organelles.
What you're looking at
here is just the fine
complex architecture of
the endoplasmic reticulum
in a small, the edge of the cell.
In this panel right here,
what you're looking at
is the confocal volume that we've sliced
in what you would see if you were
using a confocal
microscope, so you can see
there's a huge difference
between the reality
of this organelle as revealed
by imaging at this very fine
three dimensional architecture
versus the typical
image that you would get
if you were using conventional
confocal microscopes.
Now we've been working with Harold
to look in more detail
at these organelles.
In this case we're looking at
plasma membrane mitochondria
ER endosomes that we can segment out
as you mill through these slices.
This is a two micron volume of the cell.
Four nanometer voxels
and you can color code
each of these different organelles
to see how they're arranged
relative to each other.
Now, the mitochondria that you can
see here in green are
intimately communicating
with the ER which is shown in red
and there's a lot of crosstalk
between these two organelles
that's absolutely critical for
calcium handling in the cell,
for reactive oxygen exchange,
as well as lipid and other
types of communication.
Well how do we localize
proteins on these organelles
and the approach that we've been taking
really builds from really
the 20 years or more of work
that people have done using
a fluorescent protein technology
which allows you to tag
proteins of interest
and then look at how they're distributed.
Now in order for us to get
high resolution protein
as well as lipid
distribution to understand
the fine architecture in these,
in a three dimensional section of a cell,
we've applied lattice
light sheet microscopy
developed by Eric Betzig and colleagues
where essentially you take
ultra thin Bessel beams
to create a thin 2D optical lattice
which is then used as a sheet
to pass through your cell of interest.
What this allows is ultra thing slicing
through a cell, which is
at a much smaller scale
than big neuronal slices, sections.
And because we have
such a thin light sheet
that's basically almost the same dimension
as the XY lateral resolution
that you get with the microscope,
you have isotropic resolution and again
it's relatively low photo toxicity
because it's a lattice sheet of light
rather than a full sheet.
So we've combined the lattice
light sheet microscope
with a point localization
or palm-like imaging
where individual molecules,
in this case we're
looking at lipid molecules
that bind and then
disassociate from membranes
and whenever they're
bound, they create a spot
on the surface of that membrane
that we can fit with very high accuracy
by point PSF centroid fitting,
and when we do that we can reconstruct
the entire sort of organelle distribution,
map it out in 3D through
lattice light sheet imaging
with combination of plotting out
all the individual
distributions of these lipids
that have been using super
resolution imaging docked in
and put in place.
Now that we have an image
of all these organelles
and this, you can see mitochondria here
and this web-like structure represents
the endoplasmic reticulum,
we can now come in
and dock in particular
proteins of interest.
I'm just going to zoom
in on this area here
because what we're
particularly interested in
or were interested in in the study,
was how proteins that are part
of the endoplasmic reticulum,
which is this large structure that expands
throughout the cytoplasm as this
tubular meshwork, how it's organized.
And so what we can do with this technology
is superimpose our distributions
of fluorescent proteins
that we've specifically,
genetically engineered and tagged
onto our, a fluorescently acquired image
using this lattice light sheet system
to dock in where these
proteins are localized,
and this is an example where we have
again all of the membranes of the cell
that have been painted out if you will
using our lipid probe
and single molecule
super resolution imaging,
and we're now correlating it
with a diffraction limited
image of Sec61 beta
tagged with an emerald,
a fluorescent probe
and you can see how they align.
This is exciting to us because
it really sets the stage
for beginning to investigate a whole slew
of different proteins
and how they localize
within this cellular system.
So we think that FIB-SEM and
lattice light sheet paint
or palm-like correlative approaches
will allow us to really
gain deeper information
about how all of these
organelles are shaped
in three dimensions, and
how different proteins
might distribute on them.
But one of the challenges
that we still face
is how many organelles are
arranged relative to each other
in a living cell context.
In particular, that's
important for understanding
how different organelles
are contacting each other
and communicating with each other.
We know for instance,
the endoplasmic reticulum
which is this sort of snake-like structure
that you can see in this EM image
is contacting virtually
every other organelle
within the cell and communicating
with those organelles
through lipid trafficking, ROS,
essentially exchange of
reactive oxygen species,
calcium signaling, many
other types of communication
is going on between these organelles
and our problem with
trying to understand that
is that we haven't been
able to look simultaneously
at all of these organelles
in a living cell context.
We can see them clearly
with electron microscopy,
but if we do fluorescent
time lapse imaging,
we're limited to imaging two
or three of these organelles
at one time, because of
this problem of overlap
in a mission spectrum.
In among the different
fluorescent proteins
that are available.
So here we have classic
fluorescent proteins
that have different emission spectrums.
CFP, GFP, YFP.
These are the emissions
spectrum for each of these
different fluorescent probes,
and the problem is their
emission spectrum is overlapping,
and what that means is that if you tag
a particular organelle with different
fluorescent probes like the
ones that I just mentioned
which are the most widely
used fluorescent probes,
and then you image essentially
you go across the emission spectrum
to look at any particular
wavelength of light,
which population of
organelle you've looked at,
you can see that you have overlap
at any particular wavelength.
So that means if you were imaging
for instance at 438 you'd
see three different,
you would not be able to
distinguish mitochondria ER
and lysosomes from each other.
It would just be one big blur,
and hence you could not distinguish
how these different
organelles are behaving
relative to each other.
So to overcome that challenge
two post docs in the lab
decided to employ a technology
called multispectral imaging
to try to unravel this
overlapping emission spectrum
and a strategy that they
used was essentially
take, if you know the emission spectra
of each of these different fluorophores,
you can then query and
observe pixel spectrum
that's a combination of one
or more of these fluorophores
and then use linear unmixing to decipher
what combination of, and in what abundance
any one or two or more
of these fluorophores
would give rise to this
particular spectrum,
and using that we can at
each pixel of our image
unmix to determine which
fluorophore is giving rise
to the signal that we're
observing at that pixel.
And so we've combined that
with lattice light sheet microscopy
to be able to image simultaneously
six different organelles
within the cell over time.
In order to do that, we've
essentially introduced
six different laser lines that
cover the visible spectrum.
That allows us to excite the
fluorophore that we've tagged
on each one of these different organelles
and then we do our linear
unmixing algorithms
to determine each, the specific spectra
associated with each organelle.
And this is what you can
see in the case of these
six different organelles that we've
introduced fluorescent tags for.
Now, this is in a single
cell, so we can superimpose
all of these signals on top of each other
to simultaneously see in
a three dimensional space
because we're using
that lattice light sheet
to move through the
whole volume of the cell,
how all of these
organelles are distributed.
Now with this technique, we can begin to
zone in on really specific measurements
in terms of organelle
distribution, localization,
essentially connectivity.
This is just a set of values for
the number of organelles
that each of these
different populations
of organelles represent,
so for instance on average in the cell
that we're looking at
there's about 89 lysosomes,
186 peroxisomes, 157 lipid droplets.
The ER occupies by far the largest volume
in this cell among all of
these different organelles.
It's about 30 times the
size of the Golgi apparatus,
which is involved in
the secretory pathway.
Eight to nine times the
size of the mitochondria
which is involved in energy
production within the cell.
Now, we can also come in and segment
these individual organelles
to look at how they are
connected to each other, how
they're contacting each other
in order to begin to understand
the communication, the cross-communication
or cross-talk in activity
that we know is so important
for how cells are
operating and communicating
with other cells in their environment.
For instance, the endoplasmic reticulum
controls the secretory pathway
together with the Golgi apparatus.
It's what's secreting
the perineural network
that we heard earlier about.
So it's critical for
us to really understand
how these organelles behave
relative to each other,
and from these types of segmented images
we can create, we've been able to describe
what we call the organelle interactome
where we just measure
the pair-wise contacts
between these different organelles
in our images of these cells,
and from that we can see
the frequency of communication
that different organelles
have with each other.
You can see here that the ER is by far
the most communicative
of all the organelles.
It's contacting everyone.
Importantly, if you look
at a single cell over time,
you can see that this
organelle interactome
is conserved over fairly
significant periods of time
and that is despite the fact
that any particular contact
that we see is relatively transient.
I should emphasize that
this interactome changes dramatically
if we perturb the cell in different ways.
We can depolymerize microtubules
or starve cells in different ways
and we dramatically change
the way these organelles
are interacting with each other.
Now this is a movie
where we've segmented out
the mitochondria as an
example of an organelle
that is intimately communicating
with the endoplasmic reticulum.
On the right hand side
represents the surface,
all of the surface sites of mitochondria
where we see ER's signal.
So the ER is wrapping around the surface
of the mitochondria and
intimately communicating
with virtually all of those
mitochondrial elements
that we see in the cell.
This contact we think is what's,
we think there's calcium flux
between the ER and mitochondria.
That calcium is playing an important role
for mitochondrial output,
how much energy is being
produced by the mitochondria.
We also know there's lipid and cholesterol
being transferred across
these contact sites,
and importantly reactive oxygen, ROS,
reactive oxygen species
is being trafficked
across those contacts,
which could play a big role
in the disulfide bond formation
and protein remodeling
occurring in the endoplasmic reticulum.
Now let's focus in on the ER for a second.
It occupies 25% of the cell cytoplasm.
We can measure that using
our lattice light sheet
three dimensional reconstruction.
What is interesting is that if we plot out
the position of the ER over
a 15 minute time period
which you can see in this movie,
what we find is that the
ER has pretty much explored
the entire cytoplasm over just 15 minutes.
So it is a very dynamic organelle
that has lots of capability
of communicating.
Now in my final two
minutes, or one minute,
I want to take you through how fast
these organelles can move.
We know that they can,
the ER has the capability
of exploring that cytoplasm.
Let's look at its dynamics
at higher resolution.
We can do this using a TIRF-SIM system.
We can see these tubule
matrices move incredibly fast.
Interestingly, the tubes themselves
undergo an oscillatory activity.
That's ATP and GTP dependent,
so it's not just thermally driven
and finally we can actually come in
and start mapping out individual proteins
that move or diffuse along the surface
of the endoplasmic reticulum
and that's what you're seeing here.
Each of these yellow spots
represent a halo tagged protein
that is associated with
the membrane of the ER
and we can begin to map
out the trajectories
of these proteins, and that's shown here
for another ER resident
protein Sec61 beta.
If you sum up all of these trajectories,
you see that these proteins,
and this is a trans-membrane
protein you're looking at,
will explore the whole
surface of that ER freely.
Now in my final movie
here, I just want to show
here's an example where
we're mapping out a protein
that actually interacts.
It's on the surface of
the ER, but it is part
of a tethering complex that brings the ER
close to the mitochondria,
and what we can see
is when we track these
individual molecules
as they diffuse across
the surface of the ER,
we can see that as they move across
the area of the ER that's in
close proximity of mitochondria
they slow down significantly.
Consistent with a transient interaction
of this tethering protein,
with a target protein on mitochondria.
So with that I want to end and say that
this field is really being
significantly impacted
by the high resolution
technology that's now available
that scans from electron microscopy
up to the fast imaging technology.
People in my lab have
been greatly impacted by
the physicists at Jenalia.
Eric Betzig and Harald in particular
who've really provided the technology
that allows us to do this
type of work, thank you.
(applause)
(pleasant music)